Ready? Yep. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab. And let's just, um,
let's just begin. Okay, cool. So, um, with our reporter and producer, lots of,
Nasir, I think the, the best place to begin it sounds like is in 2008,
I think that sounds about right. So this is Jason Deleon.
I am an associate professor of anthropology at the University of Michigan and I
direct the undocumented migration project. But, uh, back in 2008,
Jason had actually just finished Grad School and my doctoral dissertation was on
h and stone tools elicit industries of Sanlorenzo and [inaudible],
an economic and technological study about as far removed as you can be from the
stuff that I'm doing right now using them Citi and technological data from 11
domestic and non domestic contexts. Just to explain,
Jason was on his way to being an archeologist,
so he would go out into the field,
do these digs for parts of Mexico and find these little fragments of old stone
tools.
This study focuses primarily on percussion flake tools dating back to about a
thousand BC,
an industry that has often been ignored in Mesoamerican lithic analysis and then
you would write these papers.
I evaluate these models by comparing differences in the frequencies of various
tool types, you know,
and these journals that just had really just a handful of people would read.
But like many academics, and I can say this because I was an academic,
this study also finds that the introduction and adoption of prismatic plate
technology, he had this moment where just kind of
hit the wall. It's like, okay, this is enough. I'm not, I'm not doing this.
I want nothing to do with this anymore. You know,
when I finished my dissertation,
I had really become kind of disillusioned with the work that I was doing and I
had no idea what I was going to do. I remember telling my wife at one point,
I felt really bad.
I feel like I've wasted the last 10 years of my life doing archeology and to
make matters worse, I had taken this job at the University of Washington.
It's just gotten his job where he was supposed to teach the very thing he was
now sick of. Yeah, just like just an exit.
Just a full blown crisis. But then fate stepped in.
Well, Jason was preparing for one of his freshman classes.
Someone handed him a book by a writer named, um,
Luis Alberto Raya called the Devil's, uh, the devil's highway.
Five men stumbled out of the mountain pass. So sun struck.
They didn't know their own names, couldn't remember where they'd come from,
had forgotten and how long they'd been lost.
One of them wandered back up a beak. One of them was barefoot.
They were burned. Nearly black. Your Lips. Huge and cracking.
So the devil's highway is actually, well, it's a, it's a true story.
It's the three of 26 men who came to the u s hiking their way through the
Arizona desert. 14 of them died along the way.
And so I start reading it and visions of home flooded through their minds, soft,
green bushes, waterfalls, children. It just
shocked me. I mean, I knew a lot about the border leaks. I thought I did.
I'd grown up, you know, in south Texas. My parents were immigrants,
but just like couldn't believe that, um, that you know, that this was,
this is somebody's world.
They were drunk from having their brains baked in the pan.
They were seeing God in devil's days and days of walking.
I'm running out of food and they were dizzy from drinking their own urine.
You know, dying of thirst poisons clogging their systems.
At a certain point,
Jason comes across this passage where the author is describing
the things that were in these men's pockets.
Belt buckle with a fighting cock in late one wallet in the right front pocket of
his genome. Some changed, some keys and silver belt buckle, fake silver watch,
one comb. Um, you know, these personal effects.
Green handkerchief and he's trying to reconstruct the story about who these men
were that died from, from exposure. John Doe number 42 fewer genes,
colored piece of paper and pocket. Jason says, when you read that book,
a light bulb went on. I said, I bought a plane ticket.
A month later I was in the Arizona desert.
Uh,
Jason gets out to Tucson,
Arizona and he manages to convince someone from a local NGO to basically like
show him around and be his guide.
When I said I want to look at the stuff that migrants are leaving in the desert
[inaudible]
I was like, all right, you want to see this stuff?
I'm going to take you real deep into the desert and see what you,
what you're made of.
This guy just ran me through the ringer, that part of the Sonoran desert.
It's a, it's hilly covered in Sagebrush, cacti everywhere.
Red Sand and Jason's has it at a certain point, a few hours into the hike,
they walked up this incline and got to this ridge where they could kind of look
out over this huge expanse.
Just imagine like a, uh, a ravine or a wash and
Jason says he suddenly noticed that that the desert ground below them,
it was just covered in stuff over a thousand backpacks and water bottles.
I mean, the, just that much. Well,
what ends up happening is stuff gets left behind for a couple of different
reasons. If you're in route,
you might throw something down because you get so tired in your bag,
just gets so heavy.
And those things are kind of sprinkled across these migraine trails.
But once you get to the end past the checkpoint, your smuggler says, okay,
we're safe now. We've got to a new road or we can get picked up.
Someone else will show up in the truck and then they will say, all right,
the 30 of you get into this van, leave everything behind,
change your clothes so it doesn't look like you've just walked for two weeks
through this desert. Um, and so when groups were moving really big,
you would see things the size of like football fields of just stuff everywhere,
Gatorade bottles, bibles, photographs, um, toys,
the kind of random things that you might throw in your bag and say,
I'm leaving my home forever and these are the things I want to take with me.
You know, you see things like a diaper bag or a baby bottle and you wonder,
my God, you know who, who, who just came through this. Um, and what's,
what's happened to them.
So for the next several years,
Jason just keeps going back to this stretch of the Sonoran desert,
ripped clothes, fragments of closing bushes, gathering,
whatever he could find dirty socks and you know, like an archeologist,
he would collect this stuff and oh, you didn't mindset categorize it.
Cocktail dresses, high heel shoes. Try and figure out who it came from,
why it was their baby bottles, hair curlers, toys, rappers. You did this year,
sneakers, photograph after a year, socks, picking up this shoes, dresses,
backpacks, bibles, bottles. And then one day
a human arm, he finds an arm weighs between some rocks,
like an entire arm up to the shoulder. Just sort of sticking,
sticking out between two rocks. I mean,
there was no flesh other than the things that were holding the joint together.
Oh Wow. Yeah.
Jason and his guide, the folks who was there with,
they began to search the surrounding areas for other parts of the body.
I mean, really the goal is to try to find the skull. Um, because in terms of,
you know, um, identification, I mean your best luck is going to be,
if you can get, if you can get the, um, pieces of the skull,
because if you can find pieces of a skull,
maybe you can id the body and if you can id the body,
maybe you can tell the family, here's what happened to your loved one.
And so we were out there basically digging around for,
for other parts of this person. We come across a human tooth,
some little tiny bits of rib bones, but we never find the skull.
And I realized that nobody's ever gonna identify this person.
There's just not enough left of them. And this says, not,
not likely to be a case that will be solved.
Now, Jason says he knew of course, that people were dying in the desert.
But to see this,
the fragments of a person who'd basically been erased, you know,
it's very,
ah,
I mean it's kind of just, it sort of just kills you.
Eventually he began have these nightmares,
snakes coming out of the eyes about the missing skull,
bird swooping down and pecking out the eyes,
coyotes playing soccer with this person's skull and for weeks he couldn't shake
this simple question. You know what?
What did this to this person and how many other bodies like this might be out
here? How did it get to be like this?
No.
And those questions
[inaudible]
would end up sending Jason down a sort of rabbit hole,
digging in the library to forensics papers, decomposing composing flesh,
missing persons report, hikers who had gone missing historical trends,
sociology papers, demography, paper, government document, illustrations,
and the figures in the better buried in these appendices.
And over the next several years,
Jason would end up putting together this truly startling portrait of lost
stories, hidden little known
policy decisions along our southern border that completely up ended.
How I think about this issue.
The immigration issue poses real problems and challenges that we're constantly
fighting about. We will build a great wall along the southern border.
It's still never quite
sing it.
This is part one of a three part series on our southern border.
We'll be doing it today and then next week and the week after part one a hole in
the fence.
All right, so I thought I'd start started off with Jason's question.
How did it get to be like this?
How did it get to be that so many people cross into America through the desert?
Like that's the classic image you have is someone walking through the desert.
Why out of all the places along the border that you could cross,
why is it that so many people are are crossing in the hottest and most
unforgiving place imaginable and them to be?
One of the things that Jason ended up telling us about that we found most
striking was simply the numbers,
the yearly numbers of migrant deaths in the desert.
And I mean it is shocking if you look at the data,
there's a very stark moment when things shift it.
It turns out that if you're looking at the number of people dying in the Sonoran
desert, the numbers are a bit tough to pin down. But in the early nineties,
it's single digits, five bodies, one year, six bodies, another year,
seven bodies and other.
And then all of a sudden over night in the late nineties,
you go from five to 10 bodies to, to hundreds. I mean,
it used to be that if you wanted to cross the US Mexico border,
you'd go down to Sandy, to Tijuana at dusk place called the soccer field.
You would hop the fence with about a hundred other people and you would just bum
rush to the border patrol and you and half of you would get by,
would make it into the u s and nearly half would get caught,
send back and people would do it again the next day. Um,
that was a system for a long time. I mean, the, so what change? Well,
in the mid nineties there was a lot of push back up against the visibility of
offense hopping. And it,
it all kind of starts with this little known story. Um,
there's a great book by, by this Guy Timothy Dunn called, um,
blockade in the border and it's about these Latino high school students in
Texas, right on the u s Mexico.
We ended up calling the author, he mentioned Timothy Dunn,
and then getting so interested in a story that done laid out for us that we're
gonna leave Jason Behind for a while and we're going to go on a little trip.
Yes. That by the way, is code reporter Tracy Hunt. Yes. All right. Well,
so where are we gonna go? We're gonna go to El Paso.
El Paso, Texas. So yes.
So Tracy and I went to El Paso a while back.
Everything calendered like until different,
if you were just born somewhere else.
Of course he thought that if I was born somewhere else, yeah, of course. I mean,
I think about that. I feel like,
I guess I got distracted at that point. You didn't finish the conversation.
But anyway, two flags flying the American flag and the text and flag.
We went down to El Paso to visit a high school called buoy high school.
Home of the buoy bears. Guys who goes,
you guys have been suffering too much to meet,
you know, in many respects it's just, you know,
your typical American high school.
Good. Why do you bed? Yeah, baby.
Got Your a Taco Tuesdays it's ninth through 12th grade.
About 1200 students. Very good.
So please take out your notes because it's Texas, you know,
football is a big deal.
Okay.
On their campus they have a huge football stadium with those big, you know,
Friday night lights. Uh, they've got a marching band.
The pride of the south side.
It's a, yeah,
yeah. Your typical Texas high school. Yeah. But,
but there is something a little different about it and that is that almost all
the students here for here, the Lotto is here.
Jose are Mexican American, Oscar. And you know,
we actually talked to one former teacher. This is one cyber Coronado.
I was a teacher at buoy high school in the 1980s and 1990s and where did you
teach? I taught history and he said that in all his years teaching at Buoy
taught there for 21 years and never had a single English dude.
Really? Really? Yeah. Never taught a single white student.
The reason we went to buoy high school is because something happened there.
And the early nineties, something that it sort of in a,
in a kind of roundabout and, and totally unforeseeable way,
completely changed the way we think about the US Mexico border.
[inaudible]
so we're, we're, we're going to start,
the story is actually in one of one cyber Coronado's classes.
The class was immediately after lunch and,
and on this particular day that we're going to have a debate in class and one of
the debaters, one of the kids who is going to be part of the debate was late.
Yes. Uh, his name is Albert. Albert
often came [inaudible] came late to class and so we'd been waiting and waiting
and waiting for him.
10 minutes went by, 1520
and eventually he showed up being dragged in by this campus security guy,
the school security guard. And I thought, you know,
the security guard had brought him in because he was, you know,
out doing some miscreant stuff like smoking pot again. And,
and so I kind of lay into Albert for being late again. And for,
you know, not holding up his responsibilities with class,
but, but Albert's like, no, no, no, no, no.
Albert says that he had been at the handball court playing with his friends and
then when it was time to go from the court back to class,
these two border patrol agents,
this came out of nowhere and they're green uniforms demanding to see his papers.
Like, who are you? Where are you from? Let me see your Id. Yeah. And He,
Albert tries to give them his school id, but they wouldn't take it.
And they actually told him
that he needed a federal id of some sort for them to believe at all that he was
a United States citizen or belong on the campus.
And one's just standing there like [inaudible] [inaudible] border patrol.
Really? You know, I was haranguing the kid obviously,
but then three or four other students in class just kind of stepped in and said,
no, what Albert's telling you it's true.
Mm.
Not only is Albert telling the truth,
but in the last couple of weeks or to patrol had been on the handball court and
on the playing field repeatedly stopping students,
harassing students and I was quite frankly shocked.
[inaudible]
one says,
of course he knew that the border patrol was around because of where the school
is situated, which we'll talk about in a second,
but he just never understood how present they were in his students' lives.
I was having a hard time processing this, so over the next few weeks,
oh
one started asking around different students being like, Hey,
have you had anything happen with border patrol at school?
And I got literally hundreds of stories.
I was walking home from school and you know, I had my backpack on.
This is Nydia Rodriguez who was a freshman at the time
and all of a sudden I saw this truck, the a border patrol truck,
and it was eating my way.
A couple of agents got out of the track and started questioning her,
where am I from or where am I going? Basically you were all rounded up.
Arnessa Munios remembers walking to school with a bunch of kids.
We were searched her backpack
and again, you know, a couple of agents got out, started asking him questions,
so where we were born or date of birth with classes we were taking. Yeah.
Can we stop when they get out of the truck?
Marcella Delyon who was walking with a friend near school and they go,
what do you have in the bag? And I go, books, you know,
what else would I have in my bag? They're like, well, let us see.
Well, I was walking the yelled at me, hey, get over here. Ricardo, the Elma,
they sped up to me and the stopped in front of me and asked me, you know what's,
what's in the bag was like books.
One of them ripped the bag out for my hands as I was trying to pull it away from
them. The other one grabbed me and pushed me up against the truck,
forcibly took the bag away, rifled through.
It pushed me off the or. They pulled me away from the truck,
threw my bag at me and told me to get outta here.
As these stories came out,
it became clear that even the staff had had its run ins with the border patrol.
We, we talked to the assistant football coach, Ben Marijo.
He told us there was this moment he was driving with two of his football
players.
They got pulled over by the border patrol and one of them actually pointed a gun
at his head. Never had it
gun pulled on me. So I thought my life is over
and I identified myself. My name is coach Ben.
Would you coach at Buoy High School? I have two of my football players.
I would really appreciate it if you'd holster your gun and the guy barked at me.
I appreciate you if you shut your mouth and get out of the car.
Eventually the agent did holster the gun. Ben did get out of the car.
Everything was fine. What was that like
right in your was uh,
the one of the scariest things in my life.
Wow. Why was the border patrol on the grounds of the school?
Do they have some reasons? So let's, let's set the scene a little bit. Uh,
I'm more maybe because I think to understand what was going on at buoy high
school,
no, you have to understand something else. The legend of El Paso,
you have to understand how pos, there's a spirit, a flavor.
So come on and may go see it for yourself from 30,000 feet of ball.
The desert [inaudible]
right on the border of Texas, Mexico and New Mexico. It's right there.
It's right there. It's also the biggest city,
the West Texas city of El Teso
that shares a border with Mexico too.
And the other thing to know about it is that it's like,
it kind of has a mirror city on the other side of the border,
which is war is warrants. See You dad. What is the largest city on the US?
Mexico border.
So the two cities are separated by this little sliver of the Rio Grande,
but they were essentially the same city up until 1848 when the US invaded Mexico
and annexed half the country. And even now, according to Juan,
this mythical division between these two cities,
it's just doesn't exist for most of us. I mean, I go to the dentist over there.
I buy cigarettes over there. Okay. I smoke. Yes. Okay. Okay. Well,
almost everybody in El Paso knows people who live in the field. Headwaters.
Yeah.
People are feeling waters know people who have family members who live in El
Paso, and this is literally one community.
But the thing is that when everything was going down in buoy in the early
nineties male
was the community in crisis.
So come on and make them the night the Pacer,
the crisis has spilled across the Rio Grande.
In the 80s the Mexican peso crashed. Oh, dramatically.
Devalued peso is causing habit AISES in wages.
So people in Juarez started flocking new El Paso because, well,
that's where the jobs were. Like jobs in construction or childcare gardening.
Though you had tens of people getting these permits to come until a Paso legally
that then you had all these other people,
workers who can't get permits required by US law, couldn't get permits,
but they still need it to work.
Simply respond to the laws of supply and demand and so they started coming to
making illegal dashes across the border to the United States at unprecedented
number. I mean he was as high as like 10,000 people a day,
a day coming back and forth illegally basically for their commute to work.
It was chaos. It was a mess. Here
we spoke to this phone,
border patrol agent guy named David Ham at a smuggling special agent.
He told us that when, when he was on that job before dawn,
you could go down to certain parts of the Rio Grande to have 102 hundred people
lined up waiting on the river's edge. Sun come up and here they'd come.
It's morning in America and the rush hour has begun.
The rest across the Rio Grande into El Paso and there videos where you can see
this.
You see people waiting into the shallow parts of the river to cross over to El
Paso if they don't want to get wet, that can pay a young entrepreneur,
a small fee and raft across. And so for people like David,
these border patrol agents, okay, your code close about a hundred.
It becomes this cat and mouse game where
way we had always done business. They come in, you chase him,
catch him and send them back
day and night and day and night. It was, it was a never ending job
and it was something, you know,
you'd catch the same guys two or three times a shift sometimes.
So it was, it was chaos.
Obviously we're not accomplishing 100% of our mission.
And this is actually kind of hilarious. So like, um,
around this time in 1992,
there was a television interview and Dale Mussa Guedes,
he's the sector chief of the Border Patrol in El Paso.
He's wearing his green hat with his green uniform,
with the gold shield on his chest.
If we were not here and did not keep a lid on this situation
in the shots behind him,
uh, there would be just an absolute free in inflow from other countries.
You can see people climbing up the banks of the Rio Grande and just walking into
El Paso.
That's like having Wyatt Earp standing in front of three bank robbers robbing a
bank.
Exactly. And I'm like, so, okay. How many entries?
Um, all right.
So it was reported at the time that for every one migrant,
the border patrol caught there were at least three to five who snuck in and
didn't get caught.
And the border patrol said that this was because they just didn't have the
resources.
They didn't have the money or the agents to apprehend all these people that are
coming in, which finally brings us back
to buoy high school. Okay. All right. Okay. Yeah,
let's try it because there's two important things about bullying. Okay.
I'm counting my steps actually here. Okay. From the sidewalk. One,
one buoy is right, right. Four, five,
six right on the board. 49 but basically it's 50.
That was 50 steps. 50 steps from the buoy campus into Mexico.
Yeah. And to, uh,
the former assistant football coach and teacher Ben Marijo,
he showed me what's the, what is that?
This fence. Oh,
that's part of the old fancy El Paso in the 70s put up a bunch of fencing on the
border to curb illegal immigration. So it's like a, it's much taller than us,
but it was, it was pretty flimsy. They called it the Tortilla curtain.
And right at this spot across from buoy high school,
there was a hole in the fence.
Mm.
Yeah. And David Ham,
a former border patrol agent told us what that meant was that you had migraines,
you had a lot of migrants who would be coming through that hole in the fence
from buoy, a spoon.
And he claimed that it wasn't just people looking for work,
it was also people bringing in drugs.
No Way. I know that because I work,
our anti-smuggling unit would watch them come through.
And so border patrol agents had taken to just sort of hanging out around the
school on the school's property, on the football field,
across the street from the school. Like just, they were just there all the time.
There were even rumors that border patrol agents would go under cover as
students and that they would, you know, wander the halls,
that they would go into the locker rooms.
I noticed the, uh, the suburbans parked on the Bouley campus.
Yeah. Again, former buoy teacher one cyber cornetto.
But the whole reason, you know,
that I thought they were there was the chain link is cut and they need to stop
people from entering into a high school instead of realizing that what they're
doing is they're using the high school as a hunting ground
and tea and soda one,
when he started hearing about all these stories of these 14, 15,
16 year old kids getting stopped and shaken down, it wasn't about border patrol,
China's stop migrants from coming in or trying to stop drugs from coming across
the border.
It was the border patrol of simply stopping people because they were brown.
And that really, um,
this is radio angered me,
but for most of these kids
it wasn't nothing like out of the ordinary,
you know, kids like Ernesto Munoz, Ricardo v Elma,
that was just day to day life tuck it even to some of the committee members,
honey Santos had told me, Oh, don't worry about it.
Growing up in this poor neighborhood right next to the border,
just us, uh, we are live here in south El Paso.
It wasn't like a concern like, oh no, you got stop,
you go to the park and shoot some, some basketball. You'd tell your, your,
your school mates, you know, you guess what happened after school.
He was like, you know,
ha you got stopped and that's probably because your haircut or probably because
of how you're dressed or whatever.
So the students were more likely to laugh about it than be angry.
But it is us history class.
That year one started teaching his kids about civil rights,
actually getting them to debate the different ways of thinking about civil
rights,
talking about stuff like a [inaudible],
the activities which have taken place in Birmingham over the last few days.
A letter from the Birmingham jail
onto my mind, mark,
the nonviolent movement coming of age
and it's Liberte or day
Malcolm x is ballot or the bullet.
It's freedom for everybody or freedom for nobody and so the students are
learning about
wow,
farm workers strikes in California in the 1960s we learn about Cesar Chavez.
I know workers know. We learned about Dolores Huerta,
[inaudible], Karina, and it was like, okay,
I'm bringing the book and I look out the window. And third, they are borderline
patrol agents and SUV is on the parking lot. Stopping students.
I think that's when we were like, wait,
just kind of like it felt not okay.
I mean I didn't fully know exactly the letter of the law.
That's Nydia Rodriguez again,
but I knew that what they were doing was wrong and
eventually some of these students started to get together
some talk.
Do you think this is right? What do you think this is about,
Heather? You know that this is wrong.
[inaudible] talked about how we wanted things to be different.
Let's see what we can do about it because this has to stop.
Alright. Alright. That's what's up.
[inaudible]
coming up. Juan and his students fight back.
Will continue in just a moment. Let's do some more warm ups. Let's do
[inaudible].
Hi, this is Monica calling from Oakland, California.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
caught a new podcast about juvenile justice from wny c studios follows a group
of kids as they navigate their way through our criminal justice system.
These aren't stories about innocence. They ask once the kid is caught,
what happens next?
I wouldn't even wish like jail on nobody.
Like cause is not a nice place to be because if you do something or say
something wrong, you're going to get in more trouble or like down
Kai, right? The host of cod.
Listen and subscribe to caught where ever you get your podcasts.
God, Robert, lot f Tracy and hello. Ricardo and Tony.
Okay. Okay. All right. So, uh, some of these kids at Bowie high school,
they actually to this group,
Metro Metro [inaudible],
which is a Chicano civil rights group that's been around since 1960s.
It was a college group,
but these kids at buoy actually petition them to have a chapter at the high
school and, and Mecha said
sure.
We were the first ones to get a collegiate group and they asked one if he could,
you know, supervise,
we would meet about once a week and our meetings tended to be 30,
40, 50 kids packed into a classroom.
And for one of these meetings, one brought in, one of his friends,
a woman named Susan Kern, she worked for the border rights coalition.
And so she comes in and the students start telling her, you know,
what's been going on? And they ask her, do we have any rights here?
She tells him, absolutely you do. Because according to the US Constitution,
the border patrol or really any officer,
the law, they cannot stop you without reasonable cause. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
they had to have seen you cross the border or when you saw them you started
acting fidgety or you ran away or something.
They can't just arbitrarily stop you question you just because of the color of
your skin.
That's not enough to stop you because if that's the only reason they have to
stop you, then they're violating your fourth amendment right. Yeah.
The right to be protected from unreasonable searches and seizures.
Exactly. They just said, you know what, you're getting,
your rights are getting stomped all over.
Let's see what we can do about this because it needs to stop.
After Susan explained that the rights were being violated,
the conversation turned to, what are we going to do about it?
We had a lot of students who were suggesting things that were probably,
you know, slightly inappropriate. Like how about we just curse them out?
Which I thought, well maybe that's not a bad approach, but uh,
apparently according to one's friends, Susan Huff was not the right response.
That can maybe get you in trouble, can be considered assault.
And so another student said, well, what if we just run away from them? Uh, no.
Another kid was like, what if we fight back? Oh God, definitely don't do that.
[inaudible] but finally
one of the students who's been watching law and order, that'd be Mason,
you're under arrest for the attempted murder of your mother whose knew all about
saying you have the right to remain silent, the right to remain silent,
Carolyn Tyler, you have the right to remain silent. And he was like,
that's a thing.
It's your Fifth Amendment Constitutional Right.
And it's something that you typically hear.
I have, however,
been instructed by my counsel not to testify based on my Fifth Amendment
Constitutional Rights.
When rich white dudes get in trouble on the advice of counsel,
I invoke my fifth amendment privilege and respectfully declined to answer your
question, but this one buoy metro student was like,
why don't we do that? And
that's exactly what our students started doing
after that, when border patrol agents would stop students and say, Hey,
give me your papers. Some of these students would,
no, I want to use my fifth amendment rights.
I want to take the fifth amendment made a right to remain silent.
Simple as I have the right not to incriminate Iceland. Three remain silent.
I do not want to answer your questions. Sorry. I had a burp. Okay. Ready?
I have a fifth amendment right to remain silent. Remain silent.
I don't want you to go through any of my stuff, right. To remain silent.
You're not going through my backpack. I'm not talking to you.
Once you use my pivotal amendment Fifth Amendment right and the message starts
spreading around right through Maine. Silence remain. Silence, silence, silence,
silence.
That we really don't need to answer these people's questions to remind sat
silent. Yeah. That has a terrific to nail down.
[inaudible]
well, I w I'm, I'm kind of trying to imagine myself being,
being you and giving advice to these students. And on the one hand,
obviously this is their legal right not to provide this information.
On the other hand, I can imagine that, you know,
I've heard that there are these border patrol abuses. There are, uh, you know,
these,
there are times when this doesn't go well and I'm telling these students to go
out and basically, you know, stonewall these agents and they,
it could put them in harms waves and it did frequently
[inaudible]
students were harassed for this. Students were,
the most notorious case is the case of David Renteria.
And uh, the way I'll start started was June the third.
So this is David Renteria from a documentary that was made in the nineties about
buoy high school. Yes. So David Mentor Maria, he was a senior at buoy,
a legally blind student who was coming home from graduation practice.
Uh,
and this one day he and his friend are just walking down the street and a border
patrol truck rolls up.
They stopped and they asked us for, said that you and I responded, you know,
you want citizen. My friend did the same thing and they asked us again,
what is the citizenship of US citizens? So they asked us again and they said,
you're a citizen. And I just sat with time to get them and it's gone.
Check that box. And a [inaudible]
last night said it, we didn't stop that we're going to beat us up.
Feel bad to go work to the point that we going to be able to go.
A border patrol agent, gets out of the truck, comes up to David
and started threatening to break his arm. If he tried to walk away,
I felt this hand on my arm leftover. You drag it back,
you dragged it. I turned to face you and
ended up that had taken 15 minutes from exercising the right to remain silence
and he got me, slammed me, it gets a sense. And uh,
he put his neck in the back of my neck and he kicked my legs,
locked him in his face apparently. And you know,
David wasn't physically injured after that. He was freaked out.
But the reason one called this particular
incident notorious is because
[inaudible]
immediately after to local news and El Paso picked it up and started doing a lot
more reporting on, on border patrol, on buoy and so did
from the El Paso, Texas
National Ness, good morning freaking America. You know what I mean?
That's pretty huge.
The daily invasion has strained the relationship between the border patrol and
some people at buoy high school, you know, and then, and we're talking to us,
we all have rights and then our rights daily on a day to day course are being
violated. Why are they arrested?
Because we're Hispanic because the color of our skin,
because we live right on the border and because,
well we live in a really poor neighborhood and that's the only reason.
And as this news started to grow, the border patrol sector, chief Dale,
Musa guedes decided he was going to come to buoy to talk to the students.
Is that something you remember him showing up to? Oh yeah, this the music aids.
Am I going, it was kinda doing damage control right.
At that point when agent Dale Music Aids met with about 40 students to discuss
the alleged harassment, he kept us out.
We tried to contact Dell, Musa Gates Multiple Times for this story,
but he did not reply to our voicemails or emails,
but they patch great when she morning,
we were able to get footage of that meeting.
Moosa Gades kept Good Morning America out because one of the students a tape
this and then we managed to get our hands on it.
So it's like 30 40 kids from Mecha in this classroom.
And Dale Mussa guedes he was sitting in front of us wearing a suit and tie,
trying to put things into perspective. He started telling the students like,
look, the holes in the fence, hey apolo told we keep patching them up,
they keep getting here.
[inaudible] and I said, I would try to come in and I can't, I,
I don't think there's any way in the world. He'd go cold.
And you told the students they busted some people who had brought drugs through.
I now have another case [inaudible]
so music gates is like, we're essentially trying to stop the flow of drugs here.
Why are you guys complaining so much?
[inaudible] eventually you drive your hand, right?
The students started speaking up. I gotta ask a question.
Do you remember back in the borderline phone number? The days I've been in here,
back and forth on Devon,
one student stands up and says, Hey, you're harassing us.
And that's why we're upset and be your strategy for capturing border crossers
seems to beat a, heard them all into the school where they're penned in.
I mean like how would you want to be running?
You run it into a place where they can get out of the circle.
The men paddle like old people
will not stop or will not obey the law and play.
You have to add some somehow or another apprehended. I don't, I,
you know, I don't know a better way to do it. I don't know. Not at this like,
okay. Number. Right.
It's a little hard to hear, but he said not the sacrifice of our rights.
It's not, yeah. What do you mean by five on the right?
[inaudible] they do not have rights to come into United States illegally.
What did it feel like to be sitting in that meeting? I mean,
well it felt bizarre. I mean that, you know,
somebody who's denying what everybody sees with their own eyes. Yeah.
There was no face value to what, what he said. You know,
cause at that point we were sinning. A cynical about the whole situation.
And you know, you can't undo the stuff that was already done.
So the meeting goes poorly, uh,
and a bunch of the students and some of the staff, including Ben Mario,
the assistant football coach who had a gun pointed in his face, um,
they all together decide that they want to sue the border patrol.
The phone rings one day and eventually they call up this guy and said,
we're getting ready to sue the border patrol. Will you be our local counsel?
And I said, not only yes, but hell yes, I'll pass a civil rights lawyer.
Albert Armandarez Jr were you optimistic? I mean, it's,
it's never an easy job. Suing the government is not easy.
When you live on the border and working sagoon the body,
you are never optimistic that a governmental system is going to work for you.
So yeah,
October 23rd, 1992,
the trial between buoy high school and the border patrol begins.
And apparently the courtroom was pretty much divided in half. On one half.
You had the border patrol like a ton of agents in full uniform sitting there on
the other half. You had these
Buie students dressed in their finest Cyndi dresses, slacks, shirts.
Those kids were little troopers and they all got up in the stand,
told their stories.
And then eventually border patrol sector chief Dale, Mr. Gates testifies.
Do you remember what the defense's argument was? Well,
they had lots of arguments. Um,
now we can't verify the specifics of what happened in the courtroom because a
lot of the court documents had been destroyed, but Musa guedes got up there.
And his basic argument was that if you look at the u s code of federal
regulations, section 1357 powers of immigration officers and employees,
number one,
officers have the power to interrogate any alien or person believed to be an
alien as to his right to be or to remain in the United States.
And they can do that without a warrant. And then skipping down a bit from that,
um,
they can do that quote within a reasonable distance from any external boundary
of the United States. What's a, what's a reasonable distance? Oh, this is,
what's nuts is,
I don't know exactly what went into the germination of what that is,
but the distance is a hundred miles. Really? Yeah.
In that hundred mile zone, border patrol has the power to interrogate,
has the power to arrest without warrant and they can also, and I'm quoting here,
quote, search for in any railway car, aircraft,
conveyance or vehicle within that distance. And then on top of that,
within a narrower distance of 25 miles from the border,
they can go right under private property whenever they want theirs.
It's like this little zone
that's designed to prevent border patrol officers from being charged with
trespass. When patrolling the border, I crossed, examined,
she was a gate. And so
what Mussa Gates was arguing is that like if they have all this power and if
they can go on, you know,
private property right up on the border and you got this high school on the
border,
then there's no question that they can be on school property and do their job.
That's how they read that.
But they couldn't understand is they were doing it in a way that violated the
constitution and that is against the supreme law of the land.
This was Albert's argument that no matter what powers you have,
you can't violate somebody's fourth amendment rights.
You have to have a legitimate reason to stop somebody.
So, um, what did the court, um, what ultimately happened? Okay,
before this court, finally of the,
it's a findings of facts and conclusions of law. Bunton Comma,
senior district judge before this court.
It's plaintiff's motion for temporary restraining order and preliminary
injunction and memorandum of law in support pursuant to rule six [inaudible]
does that sound any like anything to you? He's saying,
here's what we got in front of me here. All right. Okay. Thank you.
The next week we, the next paragraph now jurisdiction and venue. I'm gonna.
Okay. That means keep leading on the findings of fact, the litigation,
the named individual plaintiffs, very, very bottom as
I here by order,
the court hereby enjoins the Immigration and National Naturalization Service.
The INS, which is above at the time,
was above the border patrol from stopping and questioning an individual as to
his or her right to be or remain in the United States unless the agent has
reasonable suspicion based on specific articulable facts involving more than the
mere appearance of the individual being of Hispanic descent. Okay.
That's a fancy way of saying stop judging people by their looks side. The judge.
Yes, so they won. They won.
It was just absolute elation.
It was a big celebratory school assembly and the whole school, no,
Tony Santos was there and we were there yet. Yeah. Yeah. Pepe.
There were all these parties, Davis plaques.
I think I may even have stuff on the wall up there. It was pretty awesome.
Again, for my student, Ricardo v Elma,
it was crazy to see the least [inaudible] holes at the border patrol did violate
constitutional rights. You just don't see the agents on our campus anymore.
That's the assistant football coach, Ben Marijo,
who ended up being the lead plaintiff in the lawsuit after treating us.
Like people realize I'm not like second class citizens,
not like we have to be submissive simply because they're federal agents.
You know, we, we couldn't believe that we
took on the federal government.
And one that was one of the first times that I was really proud of what our
government, you know, stands for.
And Ricardo said, coming out of federal court that day,
it was like him and seven other students and they came out and there was a bunch
of other students and faculty from the school there.
Everybody was like, cool, let's go back to school, hop in the car. Like, no,
we kind of want to bask in this. So we walked from, uh,
the federal courthouse downtown to bully highschool and you know,
and we were getting, there were, we were all just kind of tearing up.
We were proud. We were just happy and, and surprised all at once.
It was just weird.
We started our stones and you know we had camera crews and news crews waiting
for us as we were walking up. Cause I guess the,
we got wind that we were just walking back to school.
But in the wake of this victory, in the months following,
there will be a chain of events that would really drastically change the US
Mexico border forever and take us to really to where we are now.
When you, because you just, you wrote in that essay sort of just sorta,
you don't see the connection, you don't think there's a connection,
but the fact that the connection is being made still sort of weighs on you.
Of course it weighs on us. Okay.
Because I mean because of us fences were built because the fences were built.
Maybe 10,000 people have died in the desert.
[inaudible]
I didn't know when cactus among them many before that might hold some hope
men tore their faces open. Chewing Saguaros prickly pears,
leaving gutted plants.
I've looked like animals have torn them apart with a clause.
The green here, west grave.
They walked west though they didn't know it.
They had no concept anymore of destination.
They were in a vast trickery of sand.
One of them said peaches.
So how the story goes from jubilation and pride to death in the desert.
That's the subject of our next episode. This episode of our,
of our story was reported by lots of Nasir and Tracy Hunt,
produced by Matt Kielty with Bethel hop,
Tay Tracy and lots of Nasr special thanks to Timothy Dunn for writing the book
that really guided our story of we high school to Chris Swan and Kevin Lavelle
with Kva for the archival footage that they gave us.
And to Gustavo rebellious at the El Paso Independent School district principal
Francisco, or does Sam, I tell grace,
Hernandez and the rest of the staff at buoy high school. Thanks also to Maggie,
southern Gladstone from Hachette for allowing us to use excerpts from the
devil's highway. And thanks to Eric Robledo,
Michael Wells and the Parsons School of design at the new school under Susan
Kern and to Debbie Nathan. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I remember Krulwich we'll be back next week with more from the series.